et au nez, il s'agit de
cerises, de mûres, de
canneberges, mais aussi d'une
sorte de notes tropicales
[Musique] [
Musique]
c'est fait d'une manière très similaire au
beaujolais nouveau
en ce sens que nous utilisons un processus appelé macération carbonique
pour faire fermenter les raisins  et ce que nous voulons
faire en si peu de temps, c'est
créer un
vin rouge très fruité, presque juteux,
et non pas le genre de vins plus complexes et riches en
tanins que vous
feriez normalement sur 18 mois
[Musique]
c'est  pas un vin à prendre trop
au sérieux c'est une boisson amusante
et c'est vous savez prendre l'esprit
du beaujolais nouveau
en ce sens que c'est une célébration de tout
ce qui s'est
passé dans le vignoble cette année-là donc malgré
ce qui s'est passé
au niveau mondial avec la pandémie et  donc
sur ceci est un petit rayon de soleil auquel nous
pensons
pour terminer l'année
[Musique] l'
un des très rares avantages du changement climatique
est qu'il facilite notre travail pour
faire
un bon vin anglais que nous avons vu
de mon temps à  ces 25 30 dernières années
j'ai vu nos états de récolte
avancer d'au moins deux semaines en moyenne
[Musique]
donc [
Musique]
je pense que les compétitions internationales ont
contribué à mettre le vin anglais sur la
scène internationale
et certainement un bon nombre de producteurs
dont  nous-mêmes, dans une petite mesure,
commençons maintenant à exporter du
vin anglais vers diverses parties du
monde, peut-être pas tellement en France pour
le moment, mais
certainement en scandinavie un peu vers
l'amérique, le
japon, c'est là que nous semblons voir
beaucoup de nos exportations
[  Musique]
vous